was existierte vor dem urknall stephen
hawking hat dazu eine absolut
bahnbrechende erklärung in der talkshow
star talk von niederglatt heißen
erklärte er was vor dem urknall
existierte und seine erklärung ist
verblüffend und verstörend zugleich
jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
wir wissen inzwischen immer genauer was
seit dem urknall geschehen ist wie
schnell passierte es wann entstanden die
ersten sterne die galaxien und so weiter
und so fort wir können schon sehr gut
sagen und auch beweisen was da so alles
passiert ist aber was war vor dem
urknall stephen hawking hat jetzt in der
wissenschafts talkshow star talk erklärt
welche theorie er für das universum und
die zeit davor hat und das ist wirklich
ja ziemlich wie soll ich es sagen
seltsam oder unvorstellbar seine theorie
sagt nichts
wie soll das gehen da entsteht etwas aus
dem nichts
naja für ihn ist es etwas anders vor dem
urknall gab es keine zeit und wenn es
keine zeit gehabt gab es auch keinen
davor es ist also quasi unmöglich dass
davor zu ergründen das kein davor gab es
ist also nicht nur so dass davon nichts
existiert es existierte auch kein davor
es gab quasi keinen ort und keine zeit
in der bzw
dem etwas existieren hätte können das
ist schon verrückt die kritische
raumzeit des universums ist eine
geschlossene oberfläche ohne ende sie
ist eine einheit außer ihr gibt es
demnach nichts man muss sie sich wie
eine erdkugel vorstellen bei dem der
urknall der südpol ist hinter dem südpol
ist einfach nichts mehr
ich finde das eine absolut verrückte
vorstellung unser universum wäre demnach
eine 4 dimensionale kugel ohne anfang
ohne ende aber warum erleben wir dann
alles so wie wir es erleben wir sehen
nicht diese unendliche kugel auf der es
keinen anfang und kein ende gibt wir
sehen einen anfang und eine zukunft für
uns ist die zeit eine in der einrichtung
gerichtete dimension aber nach hawking
ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so diese
sicht der dinge haben wir wahrscheinlich
nur weil wir nicht anders existieren
können wir würden vielleicht verrückt
werden wenn wir diese
endlichkeit verstehen würden
teilchenphysiker spekulieren ja schon
seit jahren darüber ob es interaktionen
auf teilchen ebene mit der vergangenheit
geben könnte
mit der erklärung von hawking wäre das
verständlich er spricht auch von einer
imaginären zeit die wahrscheinlich
existiert und unsere zeit ist davon
quasi nur eine falsche sicht vielleicht
ein so wenig sowie wetter und klima das
wetter können wir sehen spüren und
können damit umgehen aber das große
ganze ist für uns einfach nicht
verständlich die komplexen zusammenhänge
wie die post die wellen in den
jetstreams die sogar kälter werden
lassen usw
die sind verleihen auf jeden fall total
unverständlich spannend wenn ihr kein
video zum thema urknall und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet einfach meine nummer
whatsapp hier gibt es einen link dafür
da geht es direkt zu meiner nummer dann
bekommt ihr die videos vor allen andern
von mir geschickt garantiert immer ihr
könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und
mit themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und dann direkt
mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken es
gibt keine schwarzen löcher stephen
hawking schmeißt alles um the hall
wieder ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran